wow this chapter is truly amazing from
garp's last hype Act of sacrifice to the
Blackbeard Pirates power through the
insane flashbacks to Kobe's crazy
Ascension to Legendary character this
chapter as I predicted last chapter mind
you remember that return of Luffy and so
much more so make sure to stay tuned for
This truly great chapter I say that in
all honesty as usual with a chapter
before a break like this one Oda
delivered big and took out the big guns
the color spread we get this week is
epic and hyping up the one piece live
action Netflix show as we see some of
the characters that will star in the
first season including Shanks buggy Miha
carlong and more so hype honestly I'm
very very hyped for this adaptation
since Oda really seems on board too and
it's not far now with the premiere date
being August 31st 2023 so about a month
and a bit away very excited for that
smash that like button if you are as
well and if you haven't joined an Akama
today by subscribing hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates but back to
this epic chapter called the last lesson
we see a flashback of GARP teaching and
specifically he's teaching a young Kobe
as well as others and that really takes
me back to the beginning of One Piece
always crazy to be reminded How Far
We've Come Garb says lesson one an old
man and a baby you are currently riding
on a boat that can hold two persons what
will you do Kobe says he will get off
and let the two of them get to safety it
hilariously GARP hits him with a truck
and tells him wrong you fool it's better
to leave the old man because he doesn't
have long to live clearly the title last
lesson and even this flashback seems to
be preparing us for the Marines leaving
the Old Guard behind since that's what
he taught them to do after all but let's
see if things will unfold quite like
that GARP tells him that they became
Marine soldiers so they could save the
future of the people and the young like
them have a lot more future than someone
like the old man in this hypothetical
example so they must live on with the
baby later GARP gets reprimanded and is
asked to not do the that lecture again
since all lives are equal but as usual
GARP doesn't care he does things his own
way and we love him for that it's
definitely a personality trait we'd
sooner associate with a pirate than a
marine but GARP managed to pull it off
and props to him for that we get a funny
translator note too that says LOL yet
you guys AKA The Marine surf Celestial
dragons who viewed their lives as more
important than low-class or inferior
species and yeah you definitely gotta be
ignoring the Celestial Dragon on
fairness to make a statement like that
Garf for his part is stubborn and says
the future of the youngsters is
Limitless and I love this optimism in a
legend like GARP I think most of us put
the old Legends on a pedestal like
Goldie Roger and GARP compared to
someone like Kobe but GARP knows that
the new generation will eventually
replace and maybe even surpass the old
and that does seem to be the point of
One Piece if you pay attention Luffy is
not just being set up to be another
pirate king but to surpass the old one
and accomplish something even Roger
couldn't because it was too early it
seems this shift where the new
generation is replacing the old is well
on its way now with the fall of first
Whitebeard and then way more recently
big mom and kaido and now even seemingly
guard for the Marines then we get a more
recent flashback to several weeks ago on
the island of women Amazon Lily Marines
are crying too because they never got
permission to do anything because
Blackbeard is a yonko and they wish to
be saved because they don't know what
Blackberry will do to them on Pirate
Island Kobe then approaches and
Blackbeard wonders if Kobe wants to wage
a full-scale war boss pointed out that
Kobe is a sword member Kobe acts like he
did as a kid and says in exchange for
800 Marine soldiers and one Battleship
he will allow himself to be taken
Blackbeard thinks he's overestimating
himself but it Hypes up Kobe further he
didn't lose in battle but allowed
himself to be captured in many ways this
is a Kobe chapter that finally for us
the readers presents him as the Epic
Marine hero he's already been called the
hero of the Marines like GARP but it was
because of something off screen and now
Otis finally on screening it for us so
to speak now back to the giant Pizarro
hand coming down on the ship in the
present cannons are doing nothing to
that hand that's how powerful it is and
how big it is they're overwhelmed by the
ridiculous power and prepared to jump
into the sea which by the way wouldn't
be that useful since school zone could
just freeze the sea and freeze time in
it on Pirate Island we return to GARP
and people turning to him for what they
should do Garb Simply Smiles and says
you can save them meaning the people on
the ship he will create an opening and
then he says Captain Kobe will step up
and destroy the giant hand even Kobe
wonders if he can even do it against
that giant Island Monster Hand GARP as
if knowing he can simply continues and
says rear Admiral grooves will protect
the ship from debris resulting from the
hands destruction and how mepo will make
sure no one gets in the way of these two
love seeing how mepo included in this
too and he will play an epic role as
we'll see they all follow orders and
people assume as probably some readers
that before that the others are useless
without GARP it's said that they can't
do anything even going so far as to call
Kobe a damn brat instead of a hero even
gruce is like bro he said you can
destroy it but do you have a bomb or
something and Kobe just says no but
he'll see what he can do and I love this
so much because I think of how cautious
Kobe used to be as a kid and how he
always doubted himself and now he has
the confidence to just wing it and trust
that he'll figure it out I love to see
it and like I said in the last chapter
Kobe would do something big here and he
is charged with pretty much doing just
that even Grouse is shocked by Kobe's
confidence saying what you can do you're
up against the hand that's capable of
crushing an entire Battleship and this
is just a great overall chapter because
everything comes together so beautifully
a dude launches a cannonball at the two
and hell mepo gets to play his role and
cuts The Cannonball taking the explosion
so that the other two don't have to yes
maybe helmeppo could have done more but
I'm still hyped that he got to partake
and be epic in his own way we jump back
to the Epic GARP to see what he's up to
kusan says where do you think you're
going with those severe wounds while
GARP says they are just Flesh Wounds you
know the usual badass anime character
thing to say in this situation GARP
calls kuzan too naive as he jumps into
action he rushes past kuson at an insane
speed mind you and heads towards the
giant skull of the Pirate Island he that
has an epic moment where he launches the
attack Galaxy divide on the skull
Pizarro's real head feels it too and
Kobe sees this as the quick opening Garb
spoke of as a result of this attack
Pizarro lifted the arm that was gonna
Crush her ship buying them some time
Kobe promises he will answer to garp's
expectations now although Pizarro seems
to be holding his skull together so it
doesn't fall apart as a result of garb's
punch he is still pretty much fine he
moves to crush the ship with a giant
freehand he still has so GARP here
bought some time but he didn't save the
day himself that's still left for Kobe
but before we can see what Kobe does we
jump into another flashback but don't
worry it's worth it it's a conversation
GARP had with how mepo saying Kobe has
improved very quickly but he seems to
have a lot of wounds he always wraps
bandages on his hand chance in the
present Kobe jumps in front of the hand
and people think he's crazy saying being
called a hero has really gotten to his
head but Garb trusts him knowing the
truth but back to the flashback Kobe
back then asked helmeppo to keep quiet
about it but Kobe knew he was a normal
person Rock Lee over here and that he
didn't have talent for fighting so he
knew increasing his effort tenfold
wasn't enough he'd have to do it 100 no
200 times more than anyone else he knew
he had to train harder and become an
outstanding Marine that could protect
everyone and GARP was obviously
impressed saying even after training
with me probably the strictest teacher
he's doing even more and how mepo said
he does it every night how mepo even
felt so bad for him that he begged him
to stop but Kobe kept going Kobe punched
a battleship bag from last chapter
continuously with his blood-soaked hands
in the present we see Garb snow and grin
and then Kobe as people say it's a hand
against an ant and that's what it looks
like but what an aunt Kobe is everyone
but GARP is telling him that he's crazy
that nothing can be done but Kobe simply
says if he can't destroy this hand
everyone will die after all if they jump
ship aokiji will just freeze them as was
pointed out he then uses honesty impact
a name much more epic than it sounds
Kobe and his Hawk he tear through the
giant arm to everyone's shock and
Pizarro cries how much it hurts his real
body now the questioning and doubting
turns to cheers and like clockwork as
people are starting to worry about the
debris Groove steps in to keep it from
falling on the ship with his clay Nest
as GARP laughs with tears of joy in his
eyes how mepo is shocked at Kobe and
groose even says since when did you have
this kind of power obviously such an
insane attack took a lot from Kobe but
helmeppo is there to save his exhausted
body so again hellmepo being useful very
nice Kobe is cheered for destroying a
hand the size of a mountain as people
start to think this is a complete
Victory and now you just need to wait
for GARP to get on board GARP phones and
saying the mission to save Captain Kobe
has been accomplished and all of them
should get away now he lies saying he'll
do something about himself he says this
day will one day be known as a threat to
all Pirates and although Kobe still
wants to turn back gruce with tears in
his eyes obeys GARP as GARP says now go
forward all of you are the future of the
Marines GARP laughs but kuzan has
pierced him with a bunch of ice and now
the rest of his body is turning into ice
as well it's a nice touch that kuzan
isn't happy about it either since
killing this Legend is also killing his
mentor and the narrator says in
tomorrow's paper the return of young
hero Captain Kobe the unknown fate of
the legendary hero vice admiral GARP in
Pirate Island and The Siege barricade
incident at the future Island Egghead by
the emperor Straw Hat Luffy will be
reported to the whole world we're told
the stage returns to Future Island and
to Luffy's hype confrontation with
kizuru and Elder and more so I'd say now
it's safe to assume that GARP is done
because like Roger before him he laughed
in his final moments and that's much
more fitting and for someone like GARP
that in the last chapter where he was
just in pain and now Kobe Rose to
replace him so there won't be a vacuum
left behind and even if he does somehow
survive based on this chapter I'd say
it's safe to assume GARP won't be a
major player moving forward as he's left
out in the capable hands of the younger
generation he has so much confidence in
so whose Victory would you say this is
let me know in the comments the Marines
for rescuing Kobe and damaging Pirate
Island the process or the Blackbeard
pirates for taking down the legendary
hero GARP on paper this definitely seems
to me like a big Blackbeard Pirate's W
since they took down a legend without
even having Blackbeard and many other
important Pirates present but Kobe using
the tragedy to fully come into his own
is no doubt significant too but if you
liked seeing former Admiral kuzan in
action this chapter then you won't want
to miss my video about all six Admirals
in history and their powers explained
you can click the link on screen to that
right now and I'll see you there